oh
it's a good way to chop a finger off
[Laughter]
my name is joe tarasco i'm the associate
director of operations for marta and i'm
lena chardulo i'm the executive chef my
name is douglas kim owner chef at
georgia noodle i'm jinping the cdc at
churchill noodle people don't know what
cdc is okay i'm the chef the cuisine i
kind of run the show also known as chef
yes and we're here to look at food
videos and react to them
this was the most unrealistic food movie
i've seen
she has good posture
she's also just very done up
okay oh that's like a lawsuit right
there yeah yeah crazy
[Music]
okay i've never seen that
[Music]
that's pretty impressive but she's
supposed to be chef yeah i don't know
like that's crazy i don't know how you
reach that point that breaking void
there's just a lot of bravado that's
been given to the idea of being a chef
but no person would ever react like that
you never know i bet there's been some
pretty good mic drops that was a little
extreme sometimes we get a guest like
that but then you i don't actually
directly go to the table at the end of
the day we're not in front of house
people one time somebody
accused us of putting butter in a dish
that we that we didn't put butter in i
actually did feel compelled and go out
to the dining room i don't think they
really cared but no i think they
absolutely didn't yeah but i did it much
more politely than that dinner was
always amazing i don't know maybe i
watched like five
and then we had a meter of fish i
actually thought that's how you actually
the only way to cut garlic growing up
i really don't know if that's sound but
i used to slice it so thin that it used
to liquefy in the pan with just a little
oil the garlic it's hardcore yeah yeah
yeah but i like that if i saw somebody
doing that i'll be like damn
really really thin garlic yeah for the
most part it'll it'll dissipate i don't
the liquify necessarily depends on the
oil you know how heat is that the olive
oil the canola oh i see this i'll just
see everything
yeah crazy i was like damn all right i
like that
some gizzard oh snap
this is very food porn
that's real chef i want i want i don't
know
just the real chef is doing it yeah
oh that's good
[Music]
what time is lunch that's it i want to
watch the whole thing i've never seen
that movie but i'm going to watch it now
that was a cool scene that's really
legit i cannot do that technique was
very sound everything looked awesome
asian cooking it's still like old school
like you need so much dedication you
wash your rice for three years before
you go talk to me things like that i
learned that way you're a cook you're a
chef oh i haven't seen what you've been
doing for years and it works and either
you cook the menu that our customers
have come to it you want to cook the
same food the same exact the same food
that he ripped apart somewhat of the
chef dilemma is like cooking comes from
a place of passion that comes from the
heart comes from who you are and you
want to express that but at the same
time you still need to ensure that
you're cooking to the overall experience
that people expect from the restaurant i
kind of understand both sides of an
aspect of it the other day is in the
name of the game is business i mean you
can be the great chef in the world but
if they know customer
then
so it's like a balancing yeah where are
you
this is my favorite part
it's like genuinely good technique being
applied here as far as from a garnishing
perspective
too bad that's not what my home kitchen
looks like food looks delicious it
definitely looked like some professional
chef helped them on the menu that's my
favorite chef movie the relationship
between him and his cooks i think is
true of like what you'd like to think of
a great chef how many women do you see
in this kitchen well i
it's not like you is it
because i am the toughest cook in this
kitchen what is this
keep your station
[Music]
information is a professional chef
seeing
someone really like kind of focus on all
of the behind the scenes this i never i
never but it makes sense i would love to
make like every new cook in a kitchen
watch that if your station is 30 dimes
your brain's dirty paying attention to
every detail makes you better at paying
attention to details period and it'll
make you a better chef she basically
became every female wetting cook evers
idol i remember like when i was like
starting i was only female these people
look down on you the things lean now is
almost like does it have to be such an
aggressive
environment oh it's still hard you
always got to prove yourself as a as a
woman in the kitchen but now i judge you
like i'm the old yeah yeah like do what
i say i added some spices it's halloween
right sauce
garnish and
christmas but why change a recipe that
is 200 years old
it doesn't matter maybe 200 years
it's long enough
so he changed it because he said it's
too old i got that but it's a fun dance
that they do turning that super
traditional dish taking that and turning
it into something very new that's what
we try to do we try to take korean
dishes which has been for a long time
and we spin with our own way it becomes
personal there's so many great versions
out there how can we be better at the
end of the day like it's it's about
creating delicious beautiful food as
long as you keep your mind open and you
you know are willing to try it you might
like it better
bradley cooper is just a little too
famous for me to picture being a chef
this is the intense
level that you're actually working in a
kitchen i felt the intenseness i was
into it a little bit they make it feel
like so much battle for each well that
was a little dramatic yeah that's real
like that kind of i've heard stories
that was your history you worked in like
that kind of kitchens a lot he looked
nice and beat up that's common no one
looks their best in the kitchen 12 plus
14 hour days five six days a week
physical labor hot uncomfortable
conditions i mean i used to work like
that i respect that people paying like
600 500 meals that's your reputation and
you know you only get a one shot it's
not fun but it's
rewarding sometimes being in the food
world these days is is kind of like like
a celebrity but behind all of that is a
really tough life it definitely takes a
lot of dedication and
you know sweat and tears but you should
still do it because if you have a
passion for it there's nothing more
rewarding than doing what you love we'll
show you yeah we'll show you let's go
enjoy the ride
bumpy ride